make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back again with another
installment of our how to kill superhero
series where as the name implies we
figure out how to bring about the demise
of our favorite superheroes or super
villains and the character that we're
discussing today has been both a hero
and a villain at various times but
whichever side of the spectrum he falls
on
he is without a doubt one of the
strongest characters in dc comics and a
character that has been brought back to
the forefront recently with the events
of dark
knight's medal we're of course talking
about superboy prime but before we
figure out how to kill what is certainly
one of the most powerful versions of
superman we'll go over his origin
and his powers so the character that
would become super boy prime was created
by elliot s
magan and kurt swann and first appeared
in dc comics presents number 87
in 1985. although he would not adopt the
moniker of superboy prime until much
later in 2006's infinite crisis number
two so the character is actually the
superman of earth prime which is
basically dc
universe's version of the earth that we
live in meaning that just like on our
earth superheroes are not real they're
simply just characters in comic books
movies and television shows
but on that earth we get a version of
kal-el coming to earth from the planet
krypton
and he's adopted by the kent as a child
and given the name clark
now clark grows up normally until the
age of 15 when haley's comet passes over
the earth which activates clark's latent
kryptonian powers which are all
basically the same powers as superman
has
superhuman strength superhuman speed
invulnerability flight x-ray vision you
guys get the deal now when earth prime
is destroyed by the anti-monitor during
the crisis on infinite earth's event
superboy battles alongside heroes from
other earth to defeat him and once the
anti-monitor is vanquished superboy goes
to a paradise dimension along with earth
2 versions of superman and lois lane
as well as alexander luther the son of
lex luthor from earth 3. now while in
this dimension
superboy prime never actually ages but
becomes embittered by the fact that he
was robbed of his childhood
and would never grow up to fulfill his
destiny of becoming superman he also
comes to hate the new earth version of
superboy connor kent for filling the
role
that he felt was rightfully his and so
during his many years in this pocket
dimension just getting madder in matter
alexander luther decides that they've
all had enough and they're going to make
their way to the dc universe and so
superboy prime starts punching the
barrier between the two realities which
not only causes the barrier to break
down
but also sends ripple effects throughout
reality altering it in several ways such
as bringing dead characters back to life
furthermore he proves himself to be
powerful enough to alter the orbits of
planets as well as change the location
of the center of the universe
not only was super boy prime able to
best martian manhunter a character on
par with superman in terms of power but
was also able to punch his way out of
the phantom zone which up to that point
was thought to be impossible
and which once again set reality
altering ripple effects throughout the
universe he's also said to be faster
than wally west who's considered to be
the fastest of all the speedsters at the
time
and was able to free himself from the
speed force despite being exposed to
constant red sun radiation which
dampened his powers
during his time in the speed force his
powers are augmented even further as he
created a conduit for himself that
captured and stored the energy of yellow
suns from which his powers are derived
following this he was able to easily
defeat the combined forces of the
justice society the teen titans the
justice league and the doom patrol and
so it should be clear by now that
superboy prime is not only one of the
strongest versions of superman that's
ever existed but is also
one of the most powerful characters in
all of comics and so with that in mind
the question becomes how do we kill him
well
first we need to address two major ways
that will not be successful because
superboy prime is a version of superman
it might seem obvious to use superman's
traditional weakness against him the
most widely known weakness of superman
is of course
kryptonite you could ask anyone that has
never even picked up a comic book
and they could likely tell you that
kryptonite is superman's weakness it's
that ingrained in pop culture but while
kryptonite does have devastating effects
on superman
superboy prime does not share that
weakness the reason for this is that in
his universe
there were no fragments of his home
planet krypton that survived the
destruction of the planet and the
fragments of krypton from other
universes are not harmful to him and so
kryptonite is not going to help us
in any way another weakness of
superman's is magic there have been
countless times throughout history that
this has been exploited and is well
established to be a part of his
character but once again
this information is useless in our
attempt to take out superboy prime
because he does not share this weakness
either we have to remember that superboy
prime comes from earth prime which is
the analog to our world so just like in
our world
magic does not exist there and so
superboy prime is not going to be
vulnerable against it
and so that's off the table as well now
simply overwhelming superboy prime is
also
not likely to give us the result that we
want when one of the guardians of the
universe tried to destroy himself
by self-destructing superboy prime
simply absorbed the resulting energy
and it only made it more powerful at
least powerful enough to destroy an
entire universe and kidnapped mr mixol
pitilic one of the strongest reality
warpers in dc comics and so we can't
just produce a powerful enough attack to
take him out either and so we're going
to have to figure out some weakness to
exploit now if you were paying attention
earlier
i mentioned that when superboy prime was
stuck in the speed force he was
constantly being exposed to red sun
radiation which dampened his powers
however
this did not seem to be overly effective
since he was able
to not only survive but build a suit
that harnessed yellow sun energy
and escaped the speed force which also
would have been impossible but i think
that clues us in to our answer here and
that is
for that as powerful as superboy prime
is he still relies on yellow sun energy
to survive and so we're going to need to
find a way
to cut him off from the supply of stored
yellow sun energy that a suit provides
and we're also going to have to block
his access to any additional sunlight
if we can do those two things he should
theoretically be no harder to kill than
the average person since kryptonians do
not have superpowers on krypton
due to the absence of a yellow sun
nearby and so i think that's our best
bet we're going to have to disrupt his
connection
with his power suit and also find a way
to block the sun's radiation from
reaching the battlefield
in order to be successful but let me
know what you guys think right if you
can think of a better way
to take out superboy prime let me know
down in the comment section if you guys
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
you